déjenme dibujar una función que sea
interesante para obtener un límite y
sólo voy a dibujar visualmente por ahora
y ya después veremos algunos ejemplos
específicos digamos que es mi eje y mi
otro eje x y que la función se ve algo
como lo que voy a hacer ahorita digamos
que es una línea en su mayor parte
excepto que tiene un agujero en algún
punto digamos aquí
ok digamos que en x igual a tiene un
agujero y déjenme oscurecer esto para
que puedan ver claramente que no está
definido ahí entonces en x igual a no
está definida la función ok
estos serán mis ejes de la fed no
perdone fx no ese es el eje y y esta es
la función
fx verdad muy bien
entonces hemos hecho ya bastantes vídeos
de límites creo que pueden saber lo que
voy a hacer si tuviera que decirle cuál
es el límite cuando x tiende a ustedes
me dirían que este punto digamos es l
sabemos de vídeos anteriores que bueno
lo puedo escribir que el límite cuando x
se aproxima aa df de x lo que esto
significa intuitivamente es que cuando
nos aproximamos aa a medida que nos
aproximamos de este lado digamos del
lado izquierdo
en cuanto entonces en fx se está
aproximando a nuestro valor el de verdad
y vemos que se aproxima por este lado
muy bien
muy bien más o menos y si nos
aproximamos por el lado derecho ya hemos
hecho límites donde sólo aproximados del
lado izquierdo o el derecho pero
realmente tenemos que ver que tanto en
la dirección positiva como negativa si
escogemos a esta x digamos fx anda por
acá si x llega aquí entonces nuestra f x
se va aproximando a l verdad oa este
valor que decimos que es el límite muy
bien entonces decimos que el límite de
fx cuando x tiende a es igual a él y
creo que ya tenemos muy clara esta
intuición o en realidad no es nada
rigurosa en términos matemáticos de cómo
definir un límite o todo lo que hemos
dicho es que nos acercamos y que nos
aproximamos a efe de x en este vídeo voy
a intentar explicar la definición de lo
que es un límite
y que tiene un rigor matemático claro
digamos lo que significa aproximarnos a
x qué es y qué significa aproximarnos a
bp de xy bueno yo lo pienso como un
juego la definición es es esta
declaración digamos esto de aquí
significa que
que siempre que puedo dar un rango
alrededor de este punto y siempre que de
ese rango cuando hablo de un rango estoy
hablando de un dominio en donde me voy a
fijar en la función entonces digamos que
tengo un rango alrededor de a una
distancia y siempre que no esté más allá
de este rango te puedo garantizar que fx
no no no estará más allá de cierta
distancia de él ok
yo lo pienso como un juego digamos este
ok a ver yo no te creo digamos que dices
que no me crees quiero ver si f x puede
estar dentro de punto 5 como una
distancia máxima de punto 5 de l así que
si tú me das si tú me das punto 5 y
dices a ver con esta definición debería
ser capaz de darme un rango alrededor de
a que me dará fx cerca de él a no más de
punto 5 verdad entonces los valores de
fx estarán siempre
el rango justo de allí y mientras
siempre y cuando estén en cierto rango
de a nuestra variable x ok entonces
déjenme déjenme pintarle un poco más
grande porque pienso que solo estoy
dibujando el mismo esquema una y otra
vez encima del que ya tenía así que
digamos que esta es nuestra fx déjenme
pongo un agujero muy grande no digo no
no tiene que haber la fuerza un agujero
pero bueno es interesante cuando lo hay
verdad así que este punto justo de aquí
es déjenme pintar los ejes nuevamente
este es el eje x
este es el eje y y este era el punto
límite déjenme ponerlo
el punto límite aquí está que era el y
este era mi punto x igual a entonces la
definición del límite volveré a esto lo
a grande porque quiero que quede claro
esto significa y esta va a ser la la
definición épsilon con épsilon y deltas
del límite veremos en si tú me
garantizas que fx si me das cualquier
distancia que quieras desde l y vamos a
llamar a esa distancia épsilon vamos a
tomar esa definición digo que no quiero
estar a más de épsilon dl y épsilon
puede ser cualquier número positivo
verdad entonces esta distancia estas dos
distancias son épsilon estas dos que
pinte de verde y para cualquier épsilon
dame cualquier número real positivo
épsilon ok
esto es el más épsilon aquí estará
elementos épsilon ok entonces nuestra
definición usando delta y épsilon nos
dice que no importa qué épsilon medes no
importa qué distancia alrededor de el
mds
yo siempre puede encontrar otra
distancia alrededor de ahí que le voy a
llamar delta ajá digamos así que vamos a
llamar a esto una delta luego acá otra
delta
ok entonces
digamos donde siempre que yo elija una
equis dentro de este rango vean entre a
- delta llamas delta yo te puedo
garantizar que mi función la función que
depende de x va a estar dentro del rango
que dista de l a lo más en epsilon ok
entonces puedo acercar lo tanto como
quiera porque yo puedo dar una épsilon
cualquiera ok eso es lo que me está
definiendo este límite es más como un
juego y lo pueden ver desde ese punto de
vista porque si tú me das un punto x que
se aproxima al valor a digamos que
elegimos un punto x dentro de este rango
definido por delta sale entonces podemos
garantizar que fx estará dentro del
rango que tú me específicas t con tu
épsilon para hacer esto un poco más
concreto vamos a decir con numeritos en
particular es digamos que la nuestra l
vale 2 vamos a decir que le vale 2 que
la vale 1 y la épsilon que tomamos que
era punto 5 entonces el límite cuando x
tiende a
de fx no sabemos no hemos definido bien
la fp pero digamos que es 2 ajá que es
donde tiene el agujero y me dice que si
tú me das cualquier número y lo vamos a
probar en un par de ejemplos más
adelante digamos que si tú me das
cualquier número en este caso punto 5
entonces fx quedara entre 2.5 y 1.5 eso
es tomando la épsilon igual a punto 5
entonces podríamos decir que si elegimos
una equis dentro de no sea algún
intervalo arbitrariamente estrecho
entonces ésta fx no excederá de esos
valores digamos no sé si x es punto 9 y
1.1 digamos en en una delta igual a
punto uno entonces nuestra fx no va a
rebasar no va a rebasar el valor
y 2.5 y de 1.5 que es lo que define
nuestro rango en alrededor de la verdad
entonces déjenme escribirlo ahora sí ya
con épsilon si de altas arbitrarias solo
para hacer claros esto fue un ejemplo
concreto me diste una épsilon punto 5 y
yo tenía una delta digamos punto 1 pero
si esto es cierto si alguien escribe
esta expresión en realidad lo que te
están diciendo es esto debe que esto
debe funcionar para cualquier número
épsilon verdad para cualquier número no
sé a lo mejor éste puede ser 10
centésimos o 10 centésimos a la menos 2
no se puede podemos dar un rango
cualquiera y nosotros tenemos que
encontrar el rango alrededor de nuestro
punto a para garantizar que esté dentro
del que ustedes me dan a través de la
eps y no es verdad y por supuesto que
todo esto lo que estamos diciendo
funciona en todos los puntos de ese
intervalo excepto en a porque cuando
cuando a x está perdón
en este rango bueno podemos decir que fx
no nos sale del intervalo específico
pero en a no sabemos decir nada ok
entonces el libro dice lo siguiente el
libro que estoy usando para dar esta
lección darle una eps y lo cual quiere
filón positiva mayor que ese ok entonces
si alguien escribe esto significa que
ustedes les pueden dar cualquier épsilon
mayor que 0 y a continuación tenemos que
encontrar una vuelta tendremos que dar
una delta a la cuenta que la eps y long
es lo cerca que quieren que la función
esté del punto límite verdad entonces
entonces me permito escribir esto que el
límite cuando x tiende a de fx es igual
a l esto es lo que quiere decir que
tendremos que encontrar una delta tal
que si la distancia entre x
y el punto a no pasa de delta de hacerlo
en otro color
es decir si tomamos una equis aquí la
distancia entre de ese valor y delta no
es bueno por supuesto que debe ser mayor
que cero para que no sea el punto a pero
tampoco debe pasar esta distancia de la
delta que encontremos ok entonces
esta delta digamos y si lo ampliamos
déjenme ampliar esto aquí está mi punto
a aquí está digamos nuestra distancia
delta hacia el lado derecho y la
distancia delta del lado izquierdo
entonces siempre que seleccionemos un
valor de x que cae aquí en este rango
entonces
como elegimos x en estos valores yo
garantizo que la distancia entre la
función f x y el límite aja que es el
valor que toma el límite entonces esta
distancia no pasa de nuestra épsilon que
me dieron ok entonces a lo mejor parece
muy complicado y tengo sentimientos
encontrados acerca de lo que significa
esta definición que se encuentra en los
en los cursos de cálculo pero bueno ya
ya sabemos pensar y razonar de forma
rigurosa en cuanto a matemáticas pero ya
tenemos la intuición que es lo más
valioso y una vez que estudiamos ya
cálculo avanzado bueno entonces esto
hace mucho más sentido pero
intuitivamente es correcto verdad porque
antes estaba estaba antes perdón
estábamos hablando de lo que era
aproximarnos a cierto valor fx o
aproximarnos a cierto valor de ahí
y el límite cuando cuando vale l pues es
aproximarnos verdad entonces aquí
matemáticamente la épsilon me está
diciendo que no sobrepasamos cierto
valor verdad no estamos sobrepasando
arbitrariamente el valor entonces ya se
me acabó el tiempo de este vídeo en el
siguiente haré algunos ejemplos en donde
voy a probar límites utilizando esta
definición usando épsilon sy deltas así
que espero que puedas entenderlo
utilizando números tangibles y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo